all hail your new Queen are you my wife
or my queen I'm both bruh it is with a
heart heavier than Renee staring over
the charred body of her son that I
inform you this is the last episode of
the season but fear not season two has
been confirmed
but we probably won't get it until 2024.
this episode had some crazy departures
from the book which may have some
serious implications for season two did
Damon claim two dragons how will renera
react to Luke's death and will Lars
continue subscribing to Allison's only
fans all this and more answered in the
video I'll be saving any book spoilers
beyond episode 10 until the very end but
I'll give you a warning when that comes
and before we begin make sure to like
And subscribe so I don't have to enlist
my children in toddler Fight Club for
those of you who have watched a few of
my breakdown videos you'll know I always
do a side-by-side comparison of the
intro credits to see if anything's
changed and in episode 10 there's only
one really minor difference the first
build actor is no longer Patty considine
whose character King viserys died at the
end of episode 8. his billing has been
replaced by Matt Smith who portrays
Damon our first shot is of the painted
table as we travel Southward you'll see
the northernmost point here is the
shadow Tower one of several castles that
defend the wall as we we travel further
Southward we'll see some areas familiar
to this season like harrenhal where
Lionel and Harwin strong at their end in
the veil of Aaron which is located a bit
north of where Damon's first wife Rhea
Royce had a tragic riding accident Luke
touches the island of driftmark the
island he's set to rule when his
grandfather Corliss valarian passes in
episode 8 we learned the sea snake had
almost died from a stab wound while
ambushed in the step Stones an event
which put Luke and his brother's claim
to the throne into question Luke is not
of real valarian blood which may explain
why his grandfather is one of the
greatest Sailors ever known yet he can't
even last a few minutes on a ship
without getting seasick he believes that
he'd ruin everything if he were to take
it over and there is a reason this
episode starts and ends with Luke his
death will be the Catalyst for War as
we'll see throughout the episode Queen
rhaenyra shows tremendous restraint when
it comes to calling for war even though
all the Lords around her including her
husband chomp at the bit to wave their
dicks around rhaenyra does not let her
emotions get in the way of level-headed
judgment there is still a world in which
Bloodshed may be avoided that is until
Luke's death but I'll get into the
implications of that in a bit Rainier
essentially tells her son that she too
was frightened when given the
responsibility of ruling but it's a duty
that she will prepare him for just like
viserys prepared her you may have
noticed these two small affectionate
moments between mother and son here
which really set up the emotional weight
of Luke's death later in the episode
first is Rainier's multiple kisses on
Luke's forehead and the second they're
hand touching before flying off the
storm's end their meeting is cut short
with an announcement by member of the
kingsguard Laurent marbrand you'll
notice that some members of The King's
Guard have decided to side with rhaenyra
and others with king aegon and the fact
that many of them side with renera gives
her some legitimacy as kingsguard are
highly regarded amongst the common folk
and are symbols of the Kings or should I
say Queens power in the book The Knights
that follow Ranier are referred to as
members of the Queen's guard the other
more senior member of the Queen's guard
is Sir Stefan darklin who served under
both jaharis and viserys making his
service over 26 years long in the book
sir Stephanie's Lord commander of the
Queen's guard making him the superior to
Laurent and Eric rhenice the queen Who
Never Was arrives on Dragonstone after
her daring escape from the dragon pit
she's brought with her distressing news
both of the usurper and the King's death
the new seems so painful as to trigger
contractions from renira's baby I would
like to see the baby it's not the time
for that Werner demon wants to know what
we've all been thinking how come renice
didn't turn the greens into a KFC family
meal according to her it wasn't her War
to start and Damon just looks at her
like
disappointed at least renice has the
courtesy to tell them that the greens
are coming for rhaenyra and her children
speaking of children maester gerardus
and the handmaids are concerned for
rhaenyra and child because her baby is
not of term she's given birth five times
before and this is something new
meanwhile as the screams of her wife
echo in the background demon has
assembled a war council around the
painted table the dragon keepers are to
be conscripted and patrols set about the
perimeter to keep an eye out for any
stealth attacks and just as Kristen Cole
would train the green boys Stefan
darklin oversees the training of Jason
Luke and what better time to be summoned
by her mother than when she's in the
middle of Labor the boys are informed of
Allison's treachery and she makes very
damn sure that no one even Damon is
supposed to do anything without her
command but come on since when has Damon
ever listened add it to the chat
news arrives from evenfall the seat of
house Tarth where Brienne did much of
her training Corliss valarian's fever
has broken and he has departed but where
too the council is unsure neither rainy
snork Corliss have said which side
they're going to choose and if you watch
the coronation scene where everyone
bends the knee rhaenis is the only one
who doesn't it's pivotal that raniera
allies with the valerians their Navy
would be a tremendous Boon to their
cause but it's not that simple the sea
snake believes Damon and Ranier are
responsible for the death of their son
and daughter and that their
grandchildren are
okay baymen we get it demons boner for
war attracts the ire of his son-in-law
Jace even though demons told that the
queen wants no action taken without her
orders a demon goes ahead anyway and
sends Ravens to various houses across
the realm Damon thinks he is the Tully's
support in the bag after all Lord Grover
Tully was a friend of viserys's but
raniera knows Lord Grover Tully is
fickle and easily swayed hence why
sending a raven wasn't the best idea
yeah this is why she didn't want her
husband Uncle messing things up while
she was giving birth rhaenyra has far
more knowledge about the politics of the
kingdom and relationships with other
houses than Damon does fun fact many of
the members of house Tully are named
after Muppets such as Grover Elmo Kermit
and Oscar Tully Damon tells Jace that
he'll show him what real Loyalty means
bringing out Stefan and Lauren to renew
their oath to rhaenyra or face a fiery
death was this really necessary probably
not it's more of a way for Damon to
teach the Future King a lesson he
otherwise would not have gotten from his
mother meanwhile renyra faces a war of a
different sort just like her mother
equated in episode 1. the child bed is
our Battlefield
we must learn to face it with a stiff
lip unfortunately the child is lost the
book portrays a far more gruesome
depiction of events with a baby coming
out twisted and malformed with a hole in
its chest where the heart should have
been the child even having a stubby
scaled tail it was a girl to be named
visenya the same name she wanted to call
Baby Balon should he have been a girl
it's also the name of one of aegon the
conqueror's Sister Wives a fearsome
Warrior who rode a vegar rhaenyra
prepares the body herself as the silent
sisters Mill about in the background we
even get a brief moment with Damon as he
Mourns the death of his child the next
day the body is burned as is the
Targaryen tradition just like how the
body of Balin and Emma were burned in
episode 1 but the funeral is interrupted
by Sir Eric Cargill who we last Saw
helping renice Escape King's Landing in
episode 9 we saw him carry this Satchel
which was hiding the stolen crown of
King viserys that Allison put atop his
corpse he has brought it as a gift and
to swear his fealty to her as a gone
sworn protector he knows probably more
than anyone the type of character aegon
is he can't see someone who commits
sexual assault and throws his bastard
children into toddler Fight Club as
someone fit to rule in the tradition of
the kingsguard or Queen's guard Eric
swears to take no wife hold no land
father no children guard her Secrets
obey her commands and defend her name
and honor not gonna lie I got a little
teary-eyed here as everyone kneeled to
their new Queen [ __ ] is about to go down
the war tables adorned with Dragonstone
and Hightower pieces delineating the two
sides in the upcoming conflict Damon
introduces the queen as rinira Targaryen
the first of her name Queen of the
Andals rhoynar and the first men a lady
of the Seven Kingdoms and protector of
the realm their traditional way a king
or queen is introduced that's pretty
cool Rina hands over a cup of wine to
the queen which I thought was fun
considering rhaenyra used to do the same
thing for the king renyra asked for a
standing on their current Army we have
30 nights 100 crossbow men and 300 men
at Arms I pump those members out those
are rookie numbers in this racket as you
can tell these are some pretty pitiful
numbers as things currently stand it's
enough to defend Dragonstone but
certainly not enough to wage a conquest
in the meantime Damon has sent word to
former members of the city watch of
which he used to lead to see who'd be
willing to switch sides perhaps even act
as spies within King's Landing itself
Otto knew the dangers of this and made
it one of his first matters of business
to de-cloak any members of the city
watch loyal to Damon celtagar of claw
Island Staunton of rook's rests Massey
of stone dance bar Eamon of sharp point
and darklin of duskendale have also
pledged their support this leaves five
other large houses which could sway
either way the errands of the vale the
tullys of riverrun Starks of Winterfell
valarians of driftmark and baratheons of
Storm's end because her mother was an
Aaron before marrying viserys Rainier is
confident the errands will be in their
pocket Damon is also confident he can
get Lord Grover Tully on their side and
rhaenyra was really close with Borman
Baratheon but since his death his son
borrow process taken over making it a
wild card finally there's Lord Corliss
but we'll get to him in a sec the two
main houses of Team Green are house
Hightower and House Lannister Jason
Lannister no doubt still sulking over
his proposal gone wrong in episode 3. if
only he had crafted a better spear but
as one of the Lords reminds them does
any of this matter when you have dragons
the greens have only three while raniera
has seven with an additional three in
their possession that are currently
riderless and four more that have never
taken a rider these dragons are referred
to as wild and include one of my
favorites called the cannibal let's not
also forget the three eggs that Damon
picked up which are currently incubating
however those will take over a decade
before they can wreak any sort of Havoc
all in all this is about a 14-3 ratio
it's not looking good if you're the
greens but if there's anything we've
learned about Game of Thrones things can
turn in an instant rhaenyra rejects the
idea of sending the dragons over and
just burning the [ __ ] out of anyone who
opposes them she does not want to be the
ruler of Ash and Bone just wait until
you meet your descendant
Damon's plan is to establish a foothold
on the mainland at harrenhal the same
place Harwin and Lionel met their spicy
end from there they can cut off the West
surround King's Landing with their
dragons and have every green head
mounted on a spike within a fortnight
but as their plans developed an Envoy
from the king is sent its Auto Hightower
coming with a message from Allison in
the book it's actually Grand maester
Orwell who comes bearing the conditions
of peace and reneres strips him of his
chains and puts them on maester gerardus
now when this scene first starts the
queen is nowhere to be found making a
dramatic entrance on Cyrax just like she
did on the same steps in episode 2. only
this time she's not coming for her uncle
but for Otto and you know Rainier has
balls of steel when she lands her dragon
on the opposite side and casually walks
right through her enemies it's an
amazing sign of strength and also must
feel pretty intimidating if your Auto
with a dragon behind you and Damon in
front of you notice how the men
surrounding Otto are high tower guards
with the exception of Sir Arc with an a
who chose to decide with the greens his
brother Eric with an e is on the other
side Otto reads out the terms if rainera
bends the knee and acknowledges aegon as
king and pledges obesions to him she
will get to keep Dragonstone and
driftmark to be passed down to Jason
Luke respectively Additionally aegon the
younger and viserys II will be king
aegon Squire and cupbear with everyone
else given high places at court and
every Guardsman who sided with them
pardoned and Damon's like I would rather
feed my sons to the dragons than have
him carry Shields and cups Auto Troy's
arguing from the perspective of
legitimacy aegon Bears the crown sword
and name of the Conqueror while being
anointed by the high septum in front of
thousands as the saying goes possession
is nine tenths of the law not only that
but the greens have already sent out
generous proposals to the Starks tullys
and baratheons proposals that will
surely wither stale Oaths from decades
past renyra rips off Otto's hand of the
Kingpin and throws it away calling him a
traitor he covered his did that pin
dearly with renira unable to budge Otto
pulls out his trump card the page Ranier
ripped out of the SEPTA's book way back
in episode 1. it was a scene that showed
the bond of friendship between her and
Alison and the fact Allison has kept it
all these years shows she never lost her
love for her old friend the page itself
tells the tale of Princess nymeria a
beautiful Warrior Queen who conquered
much of Dorne will rhaenyra do the same
to Westeros well Damon Chomps at the bit
to go to war ringera holds her composure
telling Otto that he will have their
answer on the morrow this is a
well-calculated move on her part if she
can use that time to get more allies on
her side particularly the baratheons and
Starks the greens will have no choice
but to surrender and blood could be
spared demon does not like this idea the
enemy has declared war and from his
perspective rhaenyra has done nothing
calling her out in front of all the
other Lords was not a good move she has
the room cleared and renice is just
smiling like destroy him while Damon
wants to crush this open Rebellion
rhaenyra remind him they have bigger
things than their Ambitions to look
Beyond referring to the Song of Ice and
Fire a ruler who will be needed to unite
the kingdom against an upcoming Darkness
this was aegon's prophecy that was
handed down to her by viserys passed
from ruler to next in line now this is
where rhaenyra made a mistake she
assumed that Damon knew of this prophecy
at one point in time Damon was next in
line to be king so she thought her
father would have told him about this
prophecy so when Damon sees that
rhaenyra is basing her decisions on
viserys's crazy Omens and dreams he
physically chokes her dreams didn't make
his Kings
dragons did and you know they're gonna
be some people in the fan base like
choke me devil daddy choke me visceros
never telling Damon of the prophecy also
tells us that he never wanted nor saw
his brother as heir to the Throne all
this prophecy stuff was and never in the
book and is a testament to how the
writers here are really rounding out
these characters for the first time
since episode 7 we get our first shot of
Corliss valorian although rhaenice is
happy to see him alive and well she
can't help but feel abandoned by him
when she and the girls needed him most
he went off to war not cool Corliss but
his near-death experience has shown him
that renice was right his Pursuit for
the Iron Throne is over and all he wants
is to retire declare his house for no
side and watch his grandchildren grow up
if only it were that simple his two
grandchildren just happened to be
betrothed to Jason Luke and as renice
says those boys will not be safe so long
as they're gonna
so Corliss announces his support for
rhaenyra and it's the Christmas that
keeps on coming as Corliss announces his
Adventure in the stepstones these past
six years resulted in them fully under
his control and Garrison something
Rainier wanted them to do way back in
episode 6. there should have been
fortifications built the Garrison of
soldiers sent to hold our ground if we
take a look at the map here we can see
just how strategic this area is with
boats patrolling these Waters they can
cut off both trade and warships from
casterly Rock and Old Town furthermore
if they can cut off the gullet this
narrow stretch of ocean here they can
stop all sea trade from getting into
King's Landing crippling it
significantly of course they need to lay
Siege to the red keep itself which means
blocking any enemy armies from the west
and in order to amass such a force
they'd need the support of Winterfell
the Eerie and Storm's end so Jason
volunteers himself and his brother to
issue these messages on Dragon back
dragons are faster and more convincing
in swaying their allies so rainyra
orders Jace to visit his mother's cousin
the Lady Jane Aaron at the eerie and
then to kriegen Stark in Winterfell you
may remember kriegen's father
rickenstark pledges fealty to renera in
episode 1. Luke on the other hand will
travel to Storm's end to treat with
borosporatheon in the book renera
purposely sent Luke here because she
believed it easier of the two missions
it's a shorter distance than she thought
Luke would be welcomed with open arms
she makes the two of them swear that
they are to come as Messengers not
Warriors and neither of them are to
fight without fighting now [ __ ]
farting now fighting
no Rainier sends her sons off on their
respective Dragons Vermax who we saw in
episode 6 and aerax meanwhile Damon
Ventures into the dragon mount singing
in High Valyrian there he comes into
contact with the riderless dragon known
as Verma Thor who was once written by
King jaharis maybe this is why he's
singing Because Damon would have known
from his research on pentos that King
jaharis used to sing to his dragon and
this may calm it down there are two ways
we can interpret this scene since it's
not in the book demon reaching for the
dragon in it letting him touch him could
mean he's claimed two dragons according
to the book no writer has ever ridden
two dragons let alone having claim over
two at the same time so this could have
insane implications for season 2 taking
the story in directions even the book
hasn't tried he could also mean that
Damon is simply calming it down so that
his daughter Reina whose dragonless can
try claiming it on her own although in
the book she never rides vermathor I
want to know what you guys think in the
comments below Storm's end is really
living up to its name with well as storm
form Luke has arrived but not before
seeing that aemond has beat him to the
punch with vegar's massive body just
dominating the castle walls inside we
can see three of boris's daughters in
the hall with another alongside aemond
she does not look too pleased Eamonn has
offered his hand in marriage to one of
the four girls to strengthen the
Hightower alliance with the baratheons
remember in episode 7 that Eamon said
he'd do anything if it would strengthen
the family renyra seems to have
underestimated boros thinking that some
family ties and borman's oath would be
enough to win them over boy was she
wrong as Boral scoffs that rhaenyra came
with nothing to offer Luke can't even
offer his hand in marriage because he's
already betrothed to make this scene
extra creepy Eamonn removes his eye
patch showing a sapphire in its socket
it's a reminder to Luke for what he did
years ago when he tore it out on
driftmark eamond wants compensation
throwing his dagger at him to cut his
eye out but boros at least has enough
sense to not allow this Bloodshed in his
house having Luke escorted out the show
doesn't have this scene but after Luke
leaves one of boris's daughters who
wasn't chosen by Eamonn asks him quote
was it one of your eyes Luke took or one
of your balls I'm so glad you chose my
sister I want a husband with all his
Parts this is what really Sprints Eamon
to go after Luke and chase him on vegar
in the book all we really know is that
Luke and aymond went into the sky and a
few days later Luke and his dragon's
body washed ashore near Storm's end the
show does a fantastic job filling in the
blanks at what happened here and one of
the surprising things is that neither of
these boys wanted to kill the other Luke
wanted to escape and Eamonn wanted his
eye it is said under normal weather
conditions Eric's could have
outmaneuvered and outrun vegar but this
storm made it difficult for the younger
Dragon to maneuver also remember that
dragons can feel the emotions of their
riders or so it was implied in episode 3
when Damon was hit with an arrow and
koraxis responded like he did with
screams of pain so Luke here would have
been scared and his Dragon would have
felt that when an animal is scared
they'll often attack out of fear which
is what Erics does to vegan even though
Luke did not command him to do this it's
picking up on his Rider's fear and
trying to defend him keep in mind that
dragons like any animals can't be fully
tamed they could snap at any point so if
you put yourself in Vegas shoes you've
just been hit in the face with
Dragonfire of course you're going to
retaliate this is why Veigar attacks and
completely obliterates Eric's even
though Eamon tried to stop him if we
look at his face after Luke's death
Eamon is like what have I done he
clearly did not mean to kill Luke and
this is going to have massive
implications for the war to come
rhaenyra was considering options for
peace but when she's informed of her
son's death you can take one look at her
face and know
[Applause]
war is coming in season 2 and the dance
of dragons is fully underway if you want
a few book spoilers on what we can
expect in season 2 keep watching this is
your warning for those who don't want to
be spoiled in a October 11 blog post
Author George RR Martin said that it
would take 4 10 episode Seasons to do
the dance of dragons justice but I've
also heard that house of the Dragon May
extend even further and be turned into
an anthology series after the dance of
dragons is complete this could mean we
see other areas of the Targaryen Dynasty
such as aegon the Conqueror or maegor
the cruel I've also heard rumors that
Allison and viserys's fourth son daeron
who has not seen this season as he was
squiring an old town will be making an
appearance additionally we'll be seeing
a lot more dragons Jace will head off to
the Erie and Winterfell where I imagine
the Starks will play a much larger role
when they end up siding with renero now
I won't get too in depth with where the
book Heads next that's worthy of its own
video but let's just say that Luke's
death is not taken well by Damon and
reniro in one of the most Infamous
scenes in the entire Fire and Blood book
demon orders assassins by the name of
blood and cheese to infiltrate the
Castle's secret passageways and kill one
of aegon's children as Revenge these two
men Corner Helena and her children
saying they'll spare the life of the one
she loves more after Helena ends up
choosing this child they actually end up
killing the other one and Helena spirals
into madness we can also expect some
absolutely massive battles mentioned
briefly this episode was Renee Singh
she'll Patrol the gullet on maylese
ironic since it's close to there near
rook's rest that shall die during the
Battle of rook's rest it's in this
battle that aegon will suffer severe
burns and his Dragon rendered flightless
Kristen Cole will also become hand of
the king taking over Otto Hightower so
we can get an idea just out on hinged a
Christian aegon combo will become now
I've done every episode this season and
if you've enjoyed them please consider
liking subscribing and sharing and let
me know what you thought of the season
in the comments below for more bad takes
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at bigstory YT till next time
remember choke me devil daddy choke me